you
I'm sorry Jade bows I'm a lecturer in
discipline at Columbia University's
School of Continuing Education and the
Earth Institute what you're about to see
is a set of lectures on the essentials
of mathematics necessary for students
who take our master of science in
sustainability management program this
is the first of three sessions being
everyone I'm sorry for my state I'm a
bit of a klutz and but a week ago I
stepped into a pothole so so this is why
nothing is broken and so on and mostly
it's fine but it does get me a lot of
sympathy which I otherwise would not
have okay great my name is Satya Geoff
Bowes I am a lecturer in the mssm
program which you're all starting
tomorrow which you're sort of starting
today previous to this I used to teach
in the MPA for environmental science and
policy program run by the School of
International Affairs the mssm program
in some sense is an offspring of that
mpa in ESP program and i'll give you a
fuller introduction to myself into my
courses tomorrow at orientation today
we're going to talk about mathematics
I'd like this to be fairly interactive
this is a large group but please feel
free to shout out questions when you
don't understand this is a group that's
probably going to be together for a long
time so I'd like you to get
start to feel at home with each other
and and with me okay let's see this is
going to work Wow okay so i put up there
a little quote from an essay by gary
snyder anybody knows who gary snyder is
yes he was a beat poet yes and also a
sort of a poet of the deep ecology
movement and this is an essay that he
wrote about by the way you should have
received slides for tonight but I know
that some of you certainly did not so
when I get back to tomorrow I'll make
sure that you all received these slides
so there's no need to take notes and
brush and so on the the references in
there or actually hyperlinked into the
slide so you'll be able to get to the
essay if for some reason you want to
actually read the whole essay but so
this essay is about a time when Gary
Snyder was taking a trip in the
Australian outback and he's writing
about going around on a tour on the back
of a pickup truck and he was with an
aboriginal historian who was telling him
various stories about the hills over
there and the river that they just
passed he realized that the stories were
going very quickly he could barely make
out what was going on in one story
before the storyteller started narrating
something else and after about 20
minutes he realized that the stories
were meant to be told while walking not
while driving around in a pickup truck
and they were really the stories by
which the recorded memory of that tribe
was kept
and they were attached to symbols so
mountains certain rivers and so on and I
tell you the story because this has a
link to mathematics believe it or not
mathematics is not something to be done
while driving around in the back of a
pickup truck which is effectively what
we're going to be doing today because
we've got nine hours off of mathematics
and statistics and probability which we
really ought to take a couple of years
to do so this is obviously not the way
to learn mathematics but that's the
nature of our our culture and
civilization so you have to learn it in
nine hours so that's one thing the other
thing is that mathematics is a language
for us for for our civilization in the
same way that in the same way that
writing that remembering stories about
particular places might have been for
this aboriginal narrator to Gary Snyder
and so many of you may have wondered why
it was so important for you to learn
mathematics since you're presumably
interested in sustainability management
and it's not immediately obvious that
mathematics is so relevant and today we
will be today and the next couple of
days we will be doing things that may
not be quite so related but I want you
to remember that it is useful and there
will be times certainly in the next nine
hours figuratively speaking and also if
you're taking my economics of
sustainability management class in the
next 14 weeks where some of the things
you learn might seem technical or arcane
but at some point you will find them
useful okay the other thing is you
you'll need to self-select so some of
you for some of you mathematics will not
be a problem statistics will not be a
and you can safely ignore most of what I
say for the next nine hours but those of
you who know that it is a problem and
need a revision you should be working
through the problems that are in the
primer that was sent out the primer will
cover a lot of what I will cover but not
the calculus pot and I'll tell you where
to go to do problems there in a second
of course as I've said you you're going
to need mathematics in order to do
sustainability management well certainly
it's a very important part of economics
but also an important part of
quantitative analysis in general and the
science courses that you'll need to take
as part of the program in having worked
in interdisciplinary fields for a long
time I found that the intersection
between disciplines is always used to
intimidate so for example when I was
studying for my PhD an important field
was law in economics you know so looking
at laws looking at the economic
foundations of laws and since economics
was a relatively quantitative subject
and lawyers tended to ask you
mathematics and economics I found that
economists would use mathematics to
obfuscate their analysis for lawyers in
the same way in economics there were
those who were very mathematical and
those who were not so mathematical and
so the mathematicians who did economics
use mathematics
obfuscate to the economist so there's
this chain of obfuscation which often
takes place in interdisciplinary work
and it's to break through that chain
that it is important for you to learn
the disciplines and not be intimidated
by them so the key point of this math
camp but also of the sustainability
management program is to prevent the
sort of approach where you read an
article and you gloss over the equations
or you read a policy piece and you
ignore the tables or you engage with
them only slightly okay okay so here's
an example of mystification you may have
seen probably a few days ago there was
an op het about called math lessons for
Locke of wars anybody see that a couple
of people you don't have time to read
New York Times our peds but you can
again you can link to the dr pad and the
letters from the slides when once you
get them and you'll see an example of
how this is used ok here are the
resources that you want to investigate
and use if you need them obviously the
primer that was sent out there is also a
mat primer at the School of
International Affairs where I previously
taught and the link is over there if you
go to that link there are actually
problem sets which you can work through
and then you can show the solutions
immediately so I encourage you to
actually try to do some of the problems
before you show the solution
and also there are primers in in most
economics textbooks those will tend to
be more concise and are more appropriate
if you already know the material and
want a a quick review okay let me give
you the outline here so today we're
going to go very slowly we'll simply
talk about functions and equations this
should be high school mathematics so it
really should be review for everybody
and just a way to get those mental
processes working again on Thursday we
are going to attack calculus and that
will be a very dense session I expect
that there may be some students on
Thursday who have not met calculus
before or are quite rusty on calculus so
it'll be quite a lot to cover in one day
but we will we'll go through it and I
will certainly at least figuratively
hold your hand through through any pot
that may seem obscure day 3 which is
which is after schools which which is
after classes start is also going to be
quite dense and it'll be the second part
of calculus that is integration and also
probability and statistics in the primer
that went out you will have covered
everything in functions in equations and
a lot of what's in probability and
statistics there's not much in the
primer on calculus and and there's a
little bit on the statistics which I'll
show you on the third day we
is not actually in the primer also the
aim in the primer is not intimidate too
much in the summer when you're sitting
on the beach okay any questions so far
okay today what we're going to do is
talk about functions mostly linear
functions will talk about systems of
equations yes yes yes and can you tell
me your name when you know I will why
won't be offering it for the second
semester but I am being recorded so you
will have the you'll have the video
we'll talk about linear functions
equations systems of linear equations
we'll talk a little bit about special
nonlinear functions that we often use in
some of the science classes and in
economics and we'll wrap up by talking
about inverse functions and implicit
functions it will probably spend quite a
bit of time on a couple of examples okay
so what's a function
it's a rule a rule that assigns an
output to an input so you could think of
any rule as essentially a function for
example the function 2x takes any number
an arbitrary number or an arbitrary
quantity X multiplies it by 2 and gives
you the output which is 2x given that if
X is equal to five then 2x is equal to
10 right everybody feel comfortable with
the idea of function right we owe
leonhard euler the name you'll hear many
times for the notion of a function or
the mathematical definition of a
function so an example of a function
this is this this was when I taught the
math camp last year so this was fresh
this was in the news last years perhaps
less apropos today but so around this
time last year of course they were
actually maybe even two years ago there
was the the Fed had a program to write
checks to large banks that lost money so
you might imagine a policy function that
says if a bank loses X dollars then the
Fed will write them a check for 2 X
dollars okay and so that would be a
function so any bank which loses X
billion will receive 2x billion in in
low-interest loans okay so you can
represent a function in a tabular way so
when you see tables very often you're
really seeing a function
you may not see all the points in the
domain of that function in a table but
you are seeing an underlying function in
in that table you'll have a row with
inputs and a row with outputs remember
the function is just a rule that
associates inputs to outputs okay okay
this is probably a little hard to see
but let's okay so how many people here
have not met the Cartesian plane okay so
let's let's talk briefly about the
Cartesian plane it is simply a method of
graphically displaying two sets of
numbers paired sets of numbers so the
function remember gives me an output for
an input a function is a rule that
assigns an output to an input the
Cartesian plane is a way of displaying
paired sets of numbers we use the
Cartesian plane to display the graph of
a function and the graph is constructed
by taking as paired points the input and
output we usually think of the x axis as
the input as the metric on which the
input is displayed and the y axis as the
metric on which the output is displayed
so if
play the pair set of numbers 23 we
assign the value 2 to the x axis so we
move two squares of the right and we
assign the value 3 to the y axis we move
3 units up along the wire yeah okay if
you if you didn't know what a Cartesian
plane was before I'm afraid that my
explanation probably did not help you
but hopefully it it reminded you okay
okay so here's a graphical
representation of the function we just
discussed we have the x-axis the input
loss amount for the bank the y-axis the
output the loan amount received by the
bank given to them by the federalism we
could draw for every potential loss an
associated level of loan for example a
loss of five and associated level of
loan of ten join all the points together
that would be called a locus so that is
every pair of numbers that satisfies the
rule would be the definition of the
graph of a function every pair of
numbers that satisfy the rule okay this
of course only works this Cartesian
plane here the way I've drawn it only
works where you have one input and one
output there you can imagine a Cartesian
plane in many dimensions and we'll talk
about that next time when we when we
talk about multivariate function
okay let's get to a little bit of
notation y equals FX I'm sure you've
seen this obviously in the primer so
many times indicates that the variable Y
is a function f of X so X is an input
and y is an output both x and y are
variables that is their concepts that
are measurable and can vary f is the
rule that assigns f of X 2 X okay exit
the input variable so known as the
independent variable Y is the output
variable known as the dependent variable
F is the rule now a common source of
confusion is to think of f of X as a
function and this is a common source of
confusion because everybody makes that
confusion but note that the rule is
actually s an f of X is actually the
output so f is the rule and f of X is
the output because of course y is equal
to f of X and Y is the output and this
is a useful distinction to keep in mind
when you do calculus because one of the
things you'll do is change of variables
and so you want to make sure you
understand what's the function and
what's the optimum an example function
commonly seen manufacturing cost is
often thought of in economics as a
function of the quantity produced and so
you would have C as a function of Q
desired residential square footage as a
function of family size but for example
okay so suppose that I give you the
following slightly complicated function
in that it is a function of mouth two
variables suppose that profit is a
function of product development and
advertising expenditure and it is 36
thousand plus 40 X plus 30 y plus X
times y over a thousand what's the
profit of the firm spends a certain
amount on product development two
thousand two thousand dollars on product
development and a certain amount on
advertising five thousand dollars on
advertising anybody here with a
calculator I don't expect you to do this
in your head okay quick it
we can just do it we can we can just do
it we can work it out yes Richard okay
so that's a good question Richard the x
and y are separated by a comma this does
any book does everybody else know what
that signifies yes what's your name
Jenny yeah so x and y are both input
variables actually I jumped a step
because of course here I showed you a
function with a single input variable
and here i have a function with two
input variables so my apologies for that
ok so here this is the output Y is not
an output everybody see that oh ok so in
this example why is not an output f of X
comma Y is the output there are actually
two inputs x and y
so let's just let's just do this so
we've got 36 thousand plus eighty
thousand plus plus XY 10 million / it up
okay so that's three knows it yeah so 36
it's got to be 300 right 150 so it's got
yeah it's going to be more than yeah
1902 66 yeah sorry
yeah 276 though perfect okay okay so
everybody see how to apply functions
simply applying a rule on one or more
inputs to get up